Speaker 1: During one of Trump's speeches
in Iowa over the weekend, a voter confronts
Trump about the vaccines, the very vaccines
which Trump takes credit for and takes pride
in as one of his biggest accomplishments during
the COVID pandemic.
Those vaccines that his supporters mostly
are against and won't receive.
A voter says we lost a lot of people because
you supported the job.
And this gets super interesting.
Take a look at this guy.
Speaker 3: From Denver as my.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Know, we have lost people because.
Speaker 3: Of this project.
Yeah.
What were you.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, you know, everybody
wanted a vaccine at that time, and I was able
to do something that nobody else could have
done, getting it done very, very rapidly.
But I never was for mandates.
I was I thought the mandates were terrible.
And, you know, there's a big portion of the
country that thinks that was a great thing.
You understand that not a lot of the people
in this room, but there's a big but.
There is a big portion.
Speaker 1: Some people think the vaccine was
a good thing.
You know, I would have loved to have seen
Trump say when she says we've lost a lot of
people because you supported the jab.
Trump goes, Yeah, I would have preferred Trump
to say, What do you mean?
We've lost a lot of people because I supported
the jab.
What exactly are you talking about?
Force the voter to say, Well, hundreds of
thousands, millions have died from the COVID
vaccine.
Now, I think it's important, given the opportunity
to remind everybody there is still no credible
evidence about COVID vaccine related deaths.
There was a misleading report put out by a
group called the Institute for Pure and Applied
Knowledge.
They used completely bogus methods and assumptions
to estimate probably 300,000 people died from
the vaccine.
They used an excess death sort of calculation.
What's funny is they didn't even include the
possibility that the excess deaths were from
COVID, from the thing that was actually killing
people.
There was a false claim that Pfizer revealed
data that death as a possible side effect
was a common thing when people were in the
test group, the trial group or whatever.
That's been completely debunked.
What it relates to is that there are people
who died in the few months following vaccination,
which you would expect from groups of humans.
Some people die for reasons that have nothing
to do with the vaccine.
So the Pfizer one was a big thing.
Now, it is true that people occasionally die
from common vaccines, their insanely rare
cases, and they usually involve a sort of
known theoretical risk of death.
And the real numbers are so, so, so small.
A couple examples.
Anaphylaxis, which is a really severe allergic
reaction.
After any vaccine, there can be anaphylaxis
usually happens within minutes of the vaccine
can be treated with epinephrine.
The rate of anaphylaxis after vaccination
is believed to be somewhere between one in
ten cases per million vaccines administered.
And of course, the epinephrine shot will will
save most of those 1 to 10 per million.
There is something called intussusception,
which is a type of bowel obstruction.
When you get the rotavirus vaccine, which
is given to infants and young kids really
important to protect against severe diarrheal
disease, there can be a risk of interception
after the rotavirus vaccine, 1 to 5 cases
per 100,000 doses administered GBS Guillain-Barré
syndrome, very rare nerve damage disorder
can happen after the flu shot.
The risk is about 1 to 2 cases per million
doses.
And then, you know, you can look at the yellow
fever vaccine.
There's something called why slave to severe
reaction to the yellow fever vaccine.
And that is important in some parts of the
world.
The risk of that is under one case per 100,000
doses administered.
So can people die after a vaccine?
Yes.
Is it so, so, so rare?
Absolutely.
Is there any proof that people are dying from
the COVID vaccine?
There is not.
But this is what we call when a Trump voter
confronts Trump about the vaccine he created
and wants credit for.
This is losing control of the monster you
created.
I've mentioned it before, and we'll have the
clip of this interaction on our YouTube channel,
on our TikTok, on our Instagram.